I'd like to introduce you to the
filmmaker Charlie fresh who's sitting
here and who has who is a student at the
school of
environment I guess it's called now used
to be called a forestry school
and in any case and she has made a
number of videos of films before this
so she's a filmmaker and uh
there you have it
so questions
to the speaker
yeah I am so I'm Ludwig
in English I'm a visiting research at
the law school and I am a postdoc and my
PhD was about the regulation of seed
systems in sub-Saharan Africa
and specifically uh francophone Africa
Senegal and Burkina Faso and I'm from
Belgium so I know the European system a
little bit
um I
I think you're doing a very good job of
explaining and making palpable and both
for me but also for people who haven't
really worked on this perhaps
um
making palpable why it's so important to
not only have
um conservation in seed bank but also in
situ as they say Yeah in fields and and
to have this as living knowledge
um there's plenty of comments going
through my mind one of it is uh I don't
know how this comes across but at some
point you mentioned the international
unions or protection new varieties of
plants the new above
um that's actually legally not correct
oh that one shouldn't have been there so
I don't know if there's any editing you
can it can do more because it's an
intellectual property Union it doesn't
have anything to do with Market access
and what plant varieties are allowed to
be cultivated in the fields
um so far the the nasty comment what I
wanted to know is um but you've already
thought a little bit like how how did
you why did you want to make this movie
and then how it like was how did you
film this how did you produce this was
it just you was it was it with a
handheld camera and especially what
motivates you what fascinated you to
make this yeah
um thank you for your question
um it's cool that you've also researched
this and everything and I I'd love to
talk to you more about that that sounds
amazing
um yeah I've been making some since I
was
um really young I had my parents take
home videos every since I was three and
then when I was in high school my dad
gave me all the films that they had
taken over my entire childhood and and
ask for you to organize it and once I
went through all those phones then um he
was like okay now you can edit and they
both do graphic designing on the side so
they had Adobe Premiere Pro so I learned
video editing at a very young age and
started really just getting passionate
about the power of film and how it can
just take you to a different place
um and then in college I was a part of a
student-led documentary team and we
focused on social justice issues and
made a documentary every year
um and the documentary my sophomore year
we focused on refugees and receiving
communities as well in the German
context and then also in Minnesota
um and so that is when I just really
became curious about this meeting of
home and how we can create more
inclusive spaces that are embracing of
biodiversity but also cultural diversity
which is important for climate change
and just I'm multiple different levels
so just got more curious about that and
then um yeah I was retaining my Danish
dual citizenship
um two years ago before coming to Yale
School of environment and
um I met this woman who was out in the
rural Denmark and she had this lovely
Garden of seeds that had previously been
illegal in Denmark up until 2015 and she
told me this wonderful story about seed
saving in Denmark that's what let me
hear and yeah it did all the filming and
editing on my own and I just used a Sony
A7 and had some lovely supports from the
Yelp program on refugees and also from
other funders to help me get there and
do it
it's really impressive it's really it's
really cool thank you very nice
documentary
well
uh I have a techno question about the
sea the seed bag which I know a little
bit about I'm a backyard Gardener and a
seed saver I don't know how much time
you spent there so I understand the
basic premise of what that's meant to do
but you know like I have seeds it's
funny I was just planting some lettuce
seeds spring started that are maybe 10
years old and none of them were viable
anymore so how does this see in fact I
know it's very cold that's part of the
premise and why it's there but how do
they deal with the fact that like seeds
do need to be grown it's my
understanding and my experience or they
are not viable so are they not only a
repository but that they constantly have
to grow them to reseed the bank which
seems daunting on the scale of the
billions of seeds there yeah yeah there
are quite a few seeds there and the
question of germination is really
important
um and through like the countries that
deposit seeds there I know every couple
of years they'll have new deposits that
are made
um that the gene Bank in Spa Barber does
not do any of of the germination
themselves
so people would have to like send in new
varieties to replace the older ones but
the Nordic Genetic Resource Center does
do germination tests and that is yeah so
like Lisa look at sevison who is at the
end of the film
um they do germination testing
um with like all the Nordic countries
and they kind of control that make sure
that all the germination rates are good
but for the rest of the countries they
are not yet they don't help with that
can I ask you something about the
feedback in Spanish yes so they lend out
to you she's and then people have to
reproduce them and send back new ones
right so the spalbard gene bank is
almost like just like a bank so every
country that sends in their seeds they
can keep them there
um but the Nordic Genetic Resource
Center which is based in Sweden they can
send people some things out and then
they can grow them okay yeah so the the
Norwegian ones are sitting there yes and
not doing anything yes and like Rob says
well yeah don't they run out of steam
eventually yeah eventually yeah where is
the idea that they that you just want
the genetic code in there and it's not
necessarily you're saving the seed is a
viable thing well I mean sometimes seeds
are available forever because I know
that in archeology sometimes find viable
seeds that are thousands of years
they're mainly weeds but still yeah as
far as I know it's followed by it's a
backup of the backup yeah we have
Institute cultivation you have Gene
banks for like
that is this is a cgir seed bank as well
but
um it's a part of the Nordic Genetic
Resource Center and crop trust there's
like two entities there's an
international organization for
um reading varieties but also
conservation and for instance that
International Organization has a gene
bank for banana seeds and that one is in
love in Belgium and bananas too are
um yeah you cannot save banana seeds
forever so you have to renew your Gene
Bank all the time and this one is all
those different seed banks you have some
food weeds and full rice some for Maize
and I guess they do lots of the
conservation also planting it out and
every five years you have to renew it
and then they around the globe the Sea
Banks will send it to Salt bite so far
away from everywhere in the ice as a
backup of the backup so it's not they
don't have they mainly have the seats
that stay well for a long time and they
do don't do the outgrowing because of
the other seed banks that mostly okay do
the outgrowing that's why they have seed
bags everywhere don't they I mean and I
know that when a lab a leopard Farm 10
years ago
they lost their seat back yeah yeah but
then they borrowed from I don't know
where they're borrowed from
exactly and that was the first and only
time that a withdrawal has been made
from the small part but while I was
there
um there was some people from the new
Gene Bank um because yeah the first one
was destroyed but then they made a new
one in Lebanon and they had a
representative
um that came to from that team Bank to
come deliver 12 new varieties to the
spotbard global seed bulbs
um and he is a endurance athlete and he
was paralyzed from the waist down and so
you use this exoskeleton to walk up the
mountain and it was like a hike for
climate hope and it took 10 hours to
walk all the way up the mountain and we
all did it together and then he got to
deliver the new um seat so it just shows
that they have a good relationship but
they're a part of speaker actually
so they actually regrew the seats in in
Syria devastated as it is because I
don't know I I read somewhere almost
where that they had to regrow them in
Lebanon or in even in Morocco because it
was impossible I mean
their landmines everywhere in Syria stay
hard to do agriculture really
yeah they had taken them to Lebanon yeah
I have a question so I understand that
you want to increase diversity into the
seeds that we have but isn't there as
well like good risk in bringing some
um plants that are non-indigenous that
can sort of like
take over the local ones yeah I
definitely think that that is an
important risk and one of the reasons
that I think some more harsh seed
legislation came out in addition to
other reasons as well
um but I think that
um
with like careful research and testing
and making sure that things won't be
like super invasive and that they'll be
yeah good hosts to the land as well I
think that it's really important and
something that we're going to have to
look more into with climate change as we
have seed varieties a lot of monoculture
is less adaptive to climate change so
finding things that are more adaptive
and responsive is going to be more of a
need
but yeah it's definitely important to
make sure it's not super invasive the
other thing is that all this monoculture
is I mean their paints on certain shades
for various grains Etc
owned by what Monsanto somebody like
that now how did they manage to take a
painting out on seeds
yeah I think and all these laws you know
I mean okay so they don't obey the laws
of Scandinavia good for them but they do
in lots of places and
yeah yeah yeah I think
um like how harsh the legislation is now
in like intellectual property rights of
seas is really important to look at I
don't I'm not a super expert on um
intellectual property specifically just
having owning of intellectual property
right over a species or over a living
entity is kind of a bizarre Concept in
general and especially with companies
like Monsanto which is now Fair
um and just kind of capitalizing and
profiting off of
um yeah nature it's never never has
never turned out so well in the past so
yeah
yeah oh yeah I'm gonna try and weigh in
a little bit here
um so the these laws the the original I
think the poor mission of these laws
that determine what kind of seats
farmers can sell to cancel is a national
food security that's that's the bottom
line you don't want Farmers to so
whatever which would uh import plant
diseases or which would reduce yields
um which would then
um endanger food Security in Denmark
context of the entire European union or
for instance in the US there's two ways
of going about it in the U.S the
American model is
um it's all it's it's towards laws it's
it's afterwards if you're a seed company
and you sell seeds that turn out not to
germinate then you can be sued in court
and the penalties will be so high that
you have a very strong incentive to be
very careful about the seeds you
disseminate in Europe
we've somehow
um I think a worse system actually I
think it's originally coming from France
although I'm not sure we're going to do
it beforehand if you want to hand out
seats or if you want as a company you
want to distribute seeds you need to ask
permission for the specific variety you
need to register your variety that's at
the U.S conditions and those are the
same conditions for intellectual
property and for Market access but here
for Market access conditions then your
variety is registered a new variety of
weeds and then per batch of seeds that
you want to sell you also need to go
through a government procedure where
they will check on the batch of seeds
now what's what's happened here and I
think that that may be another problem
of interpretation with
um in the movie that I see is at some
point you say Denmark has the most
liberal seed loss that's I think not not
true that could be the pendulum coming
back because at Denmark and the
Netherlands are easily the two countries
in Europe I think with the most intense
agriculture the Netherlands is the
number one it's the number one exporter
Denmark has all it's very
um and they have government and and Agri
industry is so much involved that you
have a huge degree of implementation of
these laws if you go to Greece or to
Italy
you have more land races agriculture is
more small scale it's also the
Mediterranean Cuisine all these things
and what has happened is 10 years ago in
Europe
um ngos have actually scored something
out of the Victory and have been able to
put on the agenda of European Parliament
that all those seed laws that say
beforehand what you can cultivate
they're too strict and that there has to
be a conservation corrective eventually
the entire conservation directed was on
the agenda but it's ngos again that
torpedoed it because it wasn't radical
enough it didn't allow for enough
conservation I guess some kind of
compromise but I don't know what details
could have been that a country like
Denmark said hey we've gone a lot
further than many of these other
countries let's now uh try and allow
some more conversation our own country
for instance by not applying European
laws as strictly and and so I think if
you say Denmark has the most liberal uh
loss for conservation and for seed
exchange I interpret that as Denmark
having gone back from precipice of being
the most agro-industrial country
together with Netherlands
um so sorry for that yeah but I mean
this this farmer who was farming a field
for Rye and he was saying okay so we do
we use different seeds and it's
different kinds of Ryan it makes
different kind of flour but I guess he
doesn't distribute the seeds so in that
sense you know it is within the EU or
whatever rules they are about
you can't sell the seeds but there's
nothing to prevent you from actually
planting them again
sure small scale in your own kind of
stuff mostly it's that I also say it for
the comment on the most liberal seed
legislation that wasn't something that I
personally said it was something that
somebody from the Danish seed saving
um yeah Dana seed favors that as well
um and I think that these regulations on
sea diversity do come from National
Security but something that I've
witnessed in my own research and looking
at this from more of an environmental
anthropological lenses that a lot of the
seed legislation popped up around the
same time that there was a lot of
conversation around hugenics and that
there was this idea of genetic Purity
that has emerged in a cubic at Old seed
catalogs it's supposed to be something
that they will advertise for with using
the same language that a lot of people
within the Nazi regime used as well and
so I think that while there is like a
biological lens looking at how we
regulate seeds there is also a social
lens that got mixed up within this as
well which has been destructive for the
genetic diversity of Our Food Systems
yeah
but so
yeah I don't think they're so liberal in
Denmark they're just going to you know
say well this is Rule and we don't care
this is a normal Danish attitude
you know
so yeah true true and they're they're
not the most faithful
um clients of European participation
they say yeah sometimes say Brussels
there's other countries that are more
loyal to Brussels than Denmark so right
let's just say
but no but I mean if Monsanto owns uh
patent on all these agricultural Seas
well good for them but I mean they also
own the patent Bond all the horrible
uh artificial you know fertilizers
etc etc and Roundup I think is made by
them also so it seems like you know they
have it all sort of sewn up you know you
have to have our seeds and you have to
use our voices to make these seeds grow
and it becomes you know a real Monopoly
which I do think would be good if
somebody could break it up a little bit
but I don't know how extensive it is and
where
where it
it exists uh all the time and for
everybody
yeah I think I feel like in the U.S
context and probably also for the Danish
context that most agriculture is yeah
using these kinds of seeds and I think
that the more radical versions of having
seeds that are Heritage varieties is
um still a very small scale but I think
a lot of younger Farmers that I had
spoken to in Denmark they were looking
at this and saying this is not a good
system this is not a system that's gonna
be around forever because it's
destroying our climate and it's not
going to survive through certain
disasters or it's not going to be very
hospitable anymore so they have a bit of
an interest to disturb it as well so I
thought that that gave me a lot of hope
that there is a lot of young Farmers
that are doing things a little bit
differently well I guess also by now
there are a lot of people who are
interested in organic farming which
there certainly was not before
but I don't know I mean I don't know in
this country how big it is it's getting
bigger all the time I guess but
it could take many years before you know
people give up on all these various
chemicals that they use yeah
so
can you talk a little bit more about
like a dimension like the adaptation as
well that probably needs to happen even
if even if you like it or not the time
will change
yeah and just adaptation and climate
change broadly or yeah not for those
States obviously so I don't know what to
use what path do you see
um and also I guess
as in other
issues regarding the the lower income
countries with respect to the
developed ones yeah
yeah I think that this is like a really
amazing opportunity for institute and
exit you see things to work together
um and developing these seeds and this
is something that I witnessed when I
went to the Nordic Genetic Resource
Center in Sweden they had this very
popular oat milk
um company called Oatley and they're
working with them and had a whole field
of different oat varieties and for
researching what o varieties are the
most drought resistant or the most heat
tolerant or yeah what produced the most
oat seeds and so that there's some
research there which I think is helpful
and these bigger Gene Banks I think that
they have a lot of more resources so
they have
um an obligation to help with companies
and help with individuals to understand
better adaptation practices
um and I think that this can be a way
also for maybe also lower income
countries to work with um research
centers to understand
how to grow seeds but also to rely on
the local networks as well because I
think a lot of the local networks have
knowledge that these exit Eugene Banks
do not because yeah you have a situation
where you have spotbard that doesn't
have any of the like cultural knowledge
attached to the seat as well it's not
like you have like when you scan the
barcode of the seed that's kept up there
that's a recipe pops up or the history
of growth pops up either it's just a
seed so if um yeah everybody lost their
knowledge one day then there'd be
nothing to to keep that alive either
which is why cultural knowledge is
important for adaptation as well
yeah well one of your speakers in here I
forget which one the Norwegian one may
be uh was saying that yeah it's
important to save all these seeds but we
also have to say the knowledge of where
to grow them and how to grow them and
where not to do it Etc
and
yeah so all these millions of seeds and
12 Bar do they come with instructions
no
nobody is doing that no no but it says
where they came from right yes that's
where they came from yeah okay yeah the
Charlie this this could actually be if
you wanted this could be a live work if
you went because I mean you're saying it
yourself this is not something that you
can document in a way of uh we're gonna
have a database we're gonna put I don't
know zeros and ones in it or this is
something you can only document that for
um posterity via video actually yeah
um and Via Witnesses and recipes and and
yeah
perhaps there are people who they should
people should pay for this and and
perhaps you're in a position to convince
somebody to pay YouTube yeah maybe go
around go around the countryside and and
I don't know in
somewhere where there's lots of heirloom
varieties and start from there yeah yeah
I mean in some way it's a lot of work
but it's not terribly a challenging
concept right you just yeah it's a lot
of groundwork you interview people you
get some recipes you have some you know
some basic uh rubric of of how many
people you would talk to for each one
and it's a lot of groundwork but I think
that's it's a great great idea and you
could somewhat codify for each seed you
want to have this many representatives
yeah and for a country for instance take
example the uh the again the example of
Italy you don't have to do this for
Italy there's still a lot of heirloom
varieties compared to other rich
countries but the Italian Kitchen is so
well known around the world that all
these but if you I don't know I'm
thinking of a country like Mali for
instance yeah just a random example of
an African uh country
if you would go around there then
there's a lot to save and probably also
a lot of culinary knowledge and to share
later with other people and to motivate
the global public to be interested in
these like races heirloom varieties
and animalian kitchen yeah that's so
true yeah I feel like that's a really
good idea and I think that there's been
a lot of a really amazing work with like
visual anthropology and visual
storytelling within indigenous
communities in the US and Canada and
documenting traditional practices as
people are becoming older and trying to
figure out how to pass knowledge down to
younger populations but yeah even well
maybe nobody's asking any questions
yeah but then they also have the risk of
like if you do go to
um yeah countries like that are maybe
lower income or go to countries that are
really genetically rich like Mali or
something and he got published
um you have all this like knowledge
that's kept up and you really want to be
sure that it doesn't get in the wrong
hands as well because there's definitely
seed companies that'd be interested in
having that kind of knowledge
yeah
yeah there's a there's also a question
of cultural appropriation yeah
um what very often happens in in the so
I work actually in Africa I know more
about Africa and not Europe and it's
actually seed companies are not
interested in this knowledge they're not
interested in Mercy companies are not
interested in most of the crops that are
grown by uh by by traditional crops
grown by smallholder farmers in the
South and what many farmers will do is
um they will for instance they will have
a food crop which is which can be an
international traded crop also or a
problem that you find in many many
countries like rice like wheat or even
and soy or whatever and then they will
have uh for instance a cash crop like
like cocoa but they were also on the
side have some of their more traditional
veggies or other uh crops so they have
they have a diverse farming exercise and
seed companies are not interested in say
the site's operation of uh heirloom
varieties this is something that's
really on Farmers uh time Farmers books
seed companies there
they're maximally they're trying to
replace this but they there's no
marketing it's too small it's too
regionally diverse they are interested
in the other doing the cash crop and the
and uh um and and the main group crop
for uh for food and what you see there
is very often that those crops are not
uh local to the area very often
um they've come through colonialism uh
they've been introduced in other for
instance potato is in uh it's a new
world crop but you also find it in many
different places in Africa uh rice for
instance in West Africa is not
indigenous or at least not the type of
rice you find now but at the same time
what happens is that the farmers who are
not growing their traditional crop that
they've always been growing when the
entire richness of genetic diversity
they are growing all varieties of the 19
of the 1950s 1960s 1970s that still have
been introduced by the colonizer and the
problem is then that many seed companies
are actually not interested in these
markets because they're too small and
pharmaceuticals report so instead of
growing the newest commercial varieties
rice Farmers farmers are growing very
old commercial varieties of rice they
also need fertilizer that are also
genetically
as poor quality uh but that on top of
all that don't yield enough
um so in many African countries my
experience I would say that there's that
seed companies that that we need more
seed companies coming in to focus on
certain of their cultures
um
but your story is more around local
crops the veggies and and
yeah but for many farmers their main
cultivation is not in that
yeah no no you have to be rich to be to
do all this experimenting I mean
you know you couldn't do it on a
commercial scale
if you didn't know what was what was it
going to be and how was it going to turn
out you couldn't yeah
but then it's like maybe it's okay I
think
in the future like maybe it's not super
sustainable to have
huge uh
huge pots of land that are just owned by
a couple of people and yeah and maybe
that is a little optimistic you say I
feel like especially with the Bill Gates
recent decisions to buy up all the
Farmland
um but I think
um I think it's gonna have to be more
localized maybe in the future
but the thing is that
I mean there the the question is how to
balance this competing objective because
in any case you cannot and they could
not do I mean some small farmers they
also need to uh I mean sustain
themselves so it's not that they might
want to grow uh different uh variety of
plant but
at some point you also need to be able
to be like survive off of that yeah
yeah well I mean the suitcase is the
industrialization of
you know Agriculture
and yeah we have that but you know
there should be room for experimenting
and I think it's good your age is
exactly the 80s one of the the cool
things I think with the the farmer that
is like standing in the middle of the
wheat fields that I think right yeah
right field is that um like he has this
beautiful farm plant that's got yeah 12
different varieties of all these
different things growing together which
is really cool
um and as you're driving up to the farm
there are all these farms around him
that every plant is the same size
there's no birds around it's very quiet
and then you get up to his farm and
there's explosions of birds happening
everywhere it's super diverse he's not
using like fertilizers on his land and
yeah it's very it's very much a
different feeling so I think it was cool
to see like what it could be like as
well yeah
thank you for being here and showing us
documented to see you next year yes
definitely
pictures